this is a Fox News Alert two major
developments following the deaths of
four US soldiers in Niger details on the
Pentagon's new investigation into the
attack in a moment but first chief of
staff John Kelly issuing an emotional
defense at the White House this
afternoon following backlash over the
president's outreach to gold star
families as some of you may know general
Kelly's own son was killed in
Afghanistan while serving in the Marines
he rarely speaks about losing a child to
war but today he issued a sobering
message to those politicizing the deaths
of the brave servicemen who died
fighting for their country
he called for people the other day and
express his condolences in the best way
that he could and he said to me what do
I say I said to him sir there's nothing
you can do to lighten the burden on
these families well let me tell you what
I tell him let me tell you what my best
friend Joe Dunford told me because he
was my casualty officer he said Kel he
was doing exactly what he wanted to do
when he was killed he knew what he was
getting into by joining the more that 1%
he know what the possibilities were
because we're at war and when he died in
the four cases were talking about and I
assure of my son's case in Afghanistan
when he died he was surrounded by the
best men on this earth his friends
that's what the president tried to say
to a factor for families the other day I
was stunned when I came to work
yesterday morning and brokenhearted at
what I saw remember Congress doing
remember Congress who listened in on a
phone call from the president's to a
young wife and in his way tried to
express that opinion
there's a brave man a fallen hero he
knew what he was getting himself into
because he enlisted there's no reason to
enlist he enlisted and he was where he
wanted to be exactly where he wanted to
be with exactly the people he wanted to
be with when his life was taken that was
the message that was the message that
was transmitted it stuns me that a
member of Congress would have listened
in on that conversation absolutely stuns
me and I thought at least that was
sacred life that dignity of life was
sacred that's gone religion that seems
to be gone as well gold star families I
think that left and the convention over
the summer I just thought the selfless
devotion that brings a man or woman to
die in the battlefield I just thought
that that might be sacred
I still hope as you write your stories
and I appeal to America that let's not
let this maybe last thing that tell
sacred in our in our society a young man
young woman going out and giving his or
her life for our country let's let's try
to somehow keep that keep that sacred
but it eroded a great deal yesterday by
the selfish behavior of a member of
Congress powerful statement and indeed a
powerful moment that we witnessed there
are something very personal so general
Kelley not only sacrificed he's made for
this country by paying the ultimate
price and losing his son really
remarkable and very credible defense
dana of the president united states and
a conversation that the president
believed he was having private you know
with a grieving family member to express
you know his sympathies and his
appreciation for the service given so
earlier this week I talked about how
commanders-in-chief
they're asked to do things that would
crush most of us because they make
decisions that put people in harm's way
people who had signed up voluntarily we
don't have a draft here people join the
military because they think it would be
a great way to serve their country a
good way to learn and to become leaders
like General John Kelly has proved
to be and grief is uniquely personal so
is the consoling part of grief so if you
are in that position and you have to
figure out a way that you have the
responsibility to out to reach out in
some way as we've said all week it could
be a letter it could be a phone call
whatever it is that is a very private
moment and I wish that none of this had
ever happened all week I think we all
know why we are here at this moment
Federico Wilson the congresswoman who is
that the subject of this issue she had
she has just told POLITICO that general
Kelley is trying to keep his job he will
say anything there are other people who
heard what I heard general Kelley
doesn't need this job no he is sir he is
a public servant and he deserves a lot
of respect from all of us and I what I
love what about what he did today is
just to help us remember that this isn't
about commanders-in-chief and who did
what to what when this is about the gold
star families their grief and our focus
should be on them absolutely I Greg it
was a powerful moment and you know you
feel good that he's in the position he's
in well I'm hoping that his amazing
words would end this horrible news cycle
because anybody who code gets near this
story just doesn't look good except for
him I mean we when you take politics and
you add it to humans they become a
vultures and now we're trudging out poor
families as if they haven't suffered
enough and I mean he was clearly
directing this at Frederico Wilson and
there's no colorful hat is gonna hide
her shame after that after that thing
but this thing is snow balled into this
ghoulish political theater in part
because of the media because we have no
interest in stopping a snowball so we
just keep adding on we love picking at
the scabs you know and this is a scab
and we keep picking at it and so now
that helps that encourages people to
call up these families and make this a
story and there's no longer a no-go zone
in the media we will go anywhere
wherever the story takes us the
controversy is disgusting no one walks
away from this feeling good and I I just
wish that maybe the best thing that
general Kelly did which was beautiful
what he did was that he put a period at
the end of this sentence
but it sounds like for Rica quartz to
keep talking well I think that he
probably won't even respond to that he
doesn't that was classless and what he
did today was right yeah absolutely
Jesse what do you make of this new
development that she's now kind of
doubled down and now is going after
making it a personal attack against
general Kelly I mean she's the one that
really her behavior is shameful it is I
mean I think America is in good hands
with John Kelly as the White House chief
of staff people said Kimmel was the
conscience of the nation when I heard
Kelly talk today that's what really he
reminded me of he looked like an adult
lecturing children out there and he's a
huge asset Trump should deploy her much
more Reince Priebus could have never
pulled this off so my hats off to
general Kelly dad to be fair and
balanced totally unnecessary for the
president the other day to come out and
say well I make calls some other
presidents don't call you know those
calls are so hard to make we've seen the
president say how hard they are to make
he told me personally how hard they are
to make and it goes back to I believe
John Kelly told the president that
President Obama never called him when
his son died in combat in Afghanistan
but I don't want to pick that wound
anymore and I think that's over I think
the president knows that President
Clinton President Bush President Obama
all have a very special bond with the
men that serve our country and their
families as well and that it doesn't
need to be questioned but I think
President Trump has a need to contrast
himself with press presidents of both
parties Republican and Democrat and
almost all the time it serves him very
well and in this case it didn't but this
congresswoman totally disrespected the
sanctity of this call this is a solemn
moment between the commander-in-chief
and a grieving family it's a private
moment it's it's an extremely personal
moment and to snoopin that call where
the president was saying how brave
sergeant Johnson was knowing that he
would put his life at risk to serve the
country yet still did that he did it in
his Trump's blunt way I'm sure and she
completely mischaracterized it totally
disrespectful and I
doubt her sincerity about defending
military families because her voting
record she's voted against giving widows
money for burial rites she's voted
against funding the VA veterans benefits
she does not have her money where her
mouth is yes and I think this whole
story like Gregg said needs to stop okay
mama get your thoughts and reflections
on Kelly's comments and then the latest
developments well seems to me the news
was that general Kelly confirmed what
Frederica Wilson had said which is the
Donald Trump said to this grieving widow
this is what your man signed up for he
knew what he was getting into that is
not the most sympathetic empathetic
caring thing to say come on everybody so
he she he today confirmed that what
Frederica Wilson overheard and it wasn't
snooping guys she was in a car as the
car the entourage is going ahead with
the family in it to the funeral and she
overhears the conversation the president
the United States you can imagine
everybody in the car gets quiet the
president united states is on the phone
with the widow but initially it was said
oh no he never said that oh okay well
then you know Frederica Wilson maybe it
is political who knows
but then he suggested Oh Frederica
Wilson better watch yourself and say
maybe the thought was there's a tape he
taped the phone call no it turns out he
didn't I don't know but given what was
said today by general Kelley general
Kelley said he used that kind of
language in advising the president about
what to say but she made framed it she
refrained in his callous when it wasn't
callous or insensitive call to a
grieving family son I don't say that
what he said was something that I think
you know to the ears of a grieving
family it's not what you want it doesn't
work for someone who has just lost their
loved one so it's been said what we
invited was this young man had his
wife's name his children's name tattooed
on his chest he was an upstanding young
guy a real addition to our committee we
can be proud of Miss America can I add
something
just not only that if you corrupt the
what the meaning of it
if you corrupt the meaning of what he's
saying then that's true
but you're corrupting it I'm sorry I
just say that I've actually been there
for not all of them but I was there for
a significant number of meetings that
President Bush had with families of the
Fallen what's interesting is that often
the family members become the consolers
to the commander in chief and it is true
that and I've heard it myself you
sometimes will have a mom or a dad say
he was doing exactly what he wanted to
do he knew that he was serving his
country that there was danger involved
but he would have done it again or you
go to Walter Reed where you have the
wounded the first thing they say to the
president when they come in I want to
get back there with my guys I want to go
back and fight again because that's the
kind of leaders that we have trained in
our military so I think that that what
the president was trying to convey was
that he was a hero and that you should
be proud of him and I'm sorry that I
think I think it yeah for me to believe
I think here's the content here is the
real context the context is the
president had not called any of the
families of the four men who died in
Niger true so the press corps when he's
out there says to him mr. president how
come you haven't put out a statement or
call these folks then we learn oh there
was a statement prepared but it wasn't
released and now people are curious why
didn't you call and that's when he says
oh that Obama he doesn't call everybody
and people are like what where'd that
come from from what we know Obama was
extremely careful on this front in terms
of relating to the military to people
who would die so then there's a bunch of
back-and-forth who call who didn't call
did general Kelly get harnason was
general Kelly seated at a table his wife
seated at a table with the president
with other ghosts our families we learn
all of this and then the question what
was true did Frederica Wilson president
Truong did he say it didn't he say it
today we learned he did say I think what
you're doing this take if I can just get
in since I want to give my opinion on
this real quick Thanks he said tried to
comfort and a grieving family that law
had an unbearable loss and I think it
pretty disgusting that anyone would try
to manufacture some kind of political
opportunity out of this and assume that
the president would speak
disrespectfully to someone who has lost
a loved one most important person and
their life I don't believe that I don't
think people actually really believe
that I think you want to see it in the
way that is beneficial to the left that
can't give the president credit for
anything and will even take a situation
like this and try and besmirched it and
cheapen it and that's why I admire what
general Kelley said because he stood up
to these people and said shame on you
and she then went ahead and insulted
general Kelley who is also a gold star
parent right about that more than